hey 42 here the drug gangs of South
America are some of the most feared in
the world and none is more notorious
than the Medellin cartel helmed by the
legendary cocaine Kingpin Pablo Escobar
this cartel climaxed in the 1980s
selling its Sinister snow to all corners
of the globe Waging War on governments
and commanding an army of loyal soldiers
which numbered in the hundreds of
thousands whilst any sane individual
would rather shove thumbtacks into his
eyeballs than get mixed up in the deadly
world of international drug trafficking
it's no secret that those who do can
expect to be rewarded handsome one man
who profited more than most was Deep
South Daredevil Adler Berryman seal
better known by his super intimidating
cartel nickname Barry this adrenaline
addicted Aviator opted to employ his
exceptional aerial expertise for
nefarious purposes ferrying freight
loads of forbidden Frost into the USA
for Pablo Escobar himself at his Peak
Barry banked an astonishing half a
million dollars per flight but when the
law caught up with him and he was facing
a lengthy prison sentence seal decided
to save his own skin by betraying his
murderous Masters becoming one of the
top informants in the U.S government's
War on Drugs
spying on the largest and most brutal
criminal Empire on the planet was more
dangerous than Swimming with Sharks
whilst wearing bacon-clad boxer briefs
and seal knew that capture would consign
him to a watery grave Seal's life was so
extraordinary that it was turned into a
film starring Tom Cruise but of course
real life sadly never turns out quite
like the movies and for Barry seal
rating on Pablo Escobar would have
dramatic and ultimately deadly
consequences
birthed by the bayous of Louisiana in
1939 seals soared into flight lessons at
just 15. he was such a natural that
after only eight hours of tutelage his
instructor let him fly the plane Seoul
sixteen saw him as skilled pilot
dropping College to fly advertising
banners over his hometown of Baton Rouge
and by 1962 the Louisiana Army National
Guard enlisted his expertise earning him
repeat as an all-weather Ace pushing
plane and pilot past a precipice of
possibilities after leaving the National
Guard he joined Transworld Airlines and
was soon one of the youngest pilots in
the whole Fleet but what was shaping up
to be an incredibly promising career was
brought to a swift end in 1972 when
Barry first demonstrated that he was
willing to put money over morals he got
involved in a murky plot to smuggle a
thousand tons of C4 out of the U.S to
Mexico for a group who claimed to be
Cuban dissidents fighting Fidel Castro
sadly for seal it turned out they
weren't actually disgruntled Cubans at
all they were federal agents he'd been
caught in an elaborate sting operation
it should have been curtains but at the
subsequent trial some truly shoddy work
from the prosecution saw the judge
declare a mistrial and seal sauntered
away a free man admittedly a free man
without a job unsurprisingly trans-world
Airlines didn't Delight in his alleged
alliance with International armed
Smugglers and stripped him of his wings
word of Barry's misdees quickly spread
and he soon found himself blacklisted by
every airline in the U.S meaning his
days as a commercial pilot were over but
there were plenty of other ways for a
high flyer with low morals to make a
book or two by now it was the mid 70s
and with both disco and hippie culture
more popular than ever the drugs trade
was booming Barry soon found himself
back in the air in a plane packed with
pots as he brought marijuana from
Honduras into his home state of
Louisiana but it wasn't long before he
realized that smuggling cocaine which
was significantly more valuable
pound-for-pound made for far more profit
per flight
both has the regularity of Barry's
flights increased it was only a matter
of time before the law caught up with
him once again he was arrested in 1979
when he stepped out of his cockpit in
Honduras only to be surrounded by police
who searched his plane and found bundles
of drugs and an illegal rifle
this time there would be no courtroom
cock-ups to save him from The Slammer
and seal was sentenced to seven months
being locked up in Honduras might sound
like one of the worst things that could
happen to anyone but for Barry it was
rather fortuitous because it turns out
his Honduran jail was basically a giant
networking event for Smugglers during
his time Behind Bars he made friends
with several prominent criminals who
he'd go on to work with for years to
come but it was on the flight back to
the US after his release that fate
really dealt him a winning hand I
suppose because it was then that he
found himself sitting next to Roger
Reeves one of the most prolific drug
smugglers in history and a prize
employee of some Colombian bloke by the
name of Pablo Escobar
Reeves and seal hit it off at once you
know what it's like on a long flight
it's only a matter of time before you
start talking to the person next to you
and small world they make their money
smuggling drugs as well
the two formed a friendship that quickly
became a very lucrative partnership
Reeves was always on the lookout for
talented Pilots to help him with his
ever-expanding smuggling operation and
her seal was one of the very best he was
soon flying in cocaine for the Medellin
cartel at a time when Mass smuggling
techniques were still being perfected
seal turned it into an art form using
all his skills and daring to keep from
getting caught
to avoid showing up on radar he'd fly so
low over the Gulf of Mexico that his
wheels almost got wet once he hit land
he'd kill the plane's lights and put on
night vision goggles making the last
perilous stage of the journey in
CH darkness when he reached his
destination it was no good landing at
the local Airship and waiting for some
obliging baggage handlers to unload his
mountains of Narcotics
instead he would drop his Precious Cargo
into one of the many swamps in Louisiana
he then radio his team their GPS
coordinates of the Drop Zone and they
pick it up by boat
speed was of the essence Not only was
there a huge risk from the police but
the last thing he wants is an alligator
chomping on your stash as anyone with
even a passing knowledge of sub-aquassic
reptiles will tell you Coke and gazers
don't mix
system was as bold as it was
sophisticated and massively more
advanced than anything the DEA were used
to dealing with as a result he and
Reeves brought in a vast amount of
cocaine in a short space of time so much
that by 1981 seal had made around 25
million dollars but just a seal was
starting to get into the swing of some
serious smuggling he was busted for a
third time in truth the DEA had been
circling for a while tapping the pay
phones he used to set up his smuggling
trips and monitoring his movements
eventually they sent a wired up agent to
talk to him in a bar ensnaring him in a
deal to smuggle a shitload of fake
qualude tablets
having built a watertight case to DEA
finally landed the Sealy Bean hunting
and he was convicted at a trial in 1984.
this time it would be no seven month
stint seal was staring down the barrel
of 10 years behind bars which is
probably why at this point he quickly
decided the only logical course of
action was to sing like a canary at a
Carol concert he became a full-fledged
DEA informant on his first mission was
every bit as dangerous as smuggling
cocaine he was sent after the meddling
cartel seal used his connections to set
up a meeting in Colombia with some of
the most senior figures in the cartel in
attendance were the achero brothers
founding members and the king of cocaine
himself Pablo Escobar
collectively these men were worth tens
of billions of dollars all free would
make the first ever Forbes rich list a
few years later in 1987.
whatever they wanted to talk about seal
knew it was going to be big sure enough
they explained that the cartel was
moving their main production facility
from Colombia to Nicaragua where they'd
acquired a military base from the
government
was it wasn't fully operational yet and
in the meantime they needed seal to fly
a backlog a 15 000 kilograms of cocaine
from Colombia to America he instantly
agreed Not only would it play well of
the DEA but these weren't the sort of
guys you say no to if you enjoy having
all your limbs attached to your body
a month later he was due to fly but the
plane was so overloaded with drugs it
literally couldn't get off the ground
a bigger plane was acquired and seal was
soon underway but he wasn't in the air
for long on his way into land for a
scheduled Pit Stop he was shut down by
the Nicaraguan military and you guessed
it pulled off to jail
by this point he was quite the
incarceration expert but Seal's latest
stint Behind Bars didn't last long the
medley in cartel used one of their many
Connections in the Nicaraguan government
to secure the return of their Ace pilot
back to the us back home and at the
personal request of Escobar seal bought
a much bigger plane and returned to
Nicaragua to collect the cocaine but
before he left his DEA handlers fitted
it with cameras in the hopes of catching
Pablo and his Pals in the act landing at
the Airfield and waiting for the arrival
of one of the most ruthless gangsters on
the planet knowing that he had cameras
hidden in his plane must have been
absolutely terrifying the cartel was
known to brutally torture informants for
days before finally killing them Often
by decapitation with a chainsaw if they
realized sealer was spying his death
would be both slow and horrific things
looked desperate when one of the
camera's malfunctioned and started to
make a loud noise but somehow seal kept
his head and revved the plane's engine
so loud it covered up the sound it
worked and not only did he leave with
the drugs the DEA got their photos
including several showing Nicaraguan
soldiers loading drugs onto the plane
and one of Escobar himself handling
sacks of cocaine
seal had hit the jackpot
but little did he know he'd also signed
his own death warrant
the story that the Nicaraguan government
was involved in drug smuggling was
leaked to the press and became Front
Page News
seal wasn't mentioned by name but it
didn't exactly take much for the cartel
to figure out he was involved he
continued to work with the DEA Gathering
important evidence on several other
South American drug smugglers but his
dealings with the medley in cartel came
to an abrupt end
despite his success as an Informer seal
was still under active investigation on
charges of smuggling in Louisiana and
Florida and so began a bizarre period of
his life where he was appearing as the
Accused at his own trail and as a
witness of three of us for Major League
criminals he'd helped bring down
his work with the DEA protected him from
the stiffest punishments but it didn't
prove to be a total get out of jail free
card as he was sentenced to five years
probation during that time he wouldn't
be under police protection nor would he
be held in a secure location he wasn't
even allowed to carry a gun or hire
armed bodyguards
to make matters worse for the first six
months he was forbidden from leaving
Baton Rouge and told that he had to be
at his appointed accommodation every
night between 6 pm and 6 a.m in other
words anyone who wanted to find him knew
exactly where he'd be and when
and boy did people want to find him by
this point the bigwigs of the meddling
cartel had figured out that Barry seal
had Jeeps them and they wasted no time
putting a bounty on his head
half a million dollars if he was killed
and a cool million if he was delivered
alive so they could take a closer look
at his inits
given the conditions the judge made him
agree to it's no surprise what happened
only three weeks into Seal's probation
he was outside the Salvation Army Center
where he'd been staying when a man
jumped out of a car spraying bullets
from a machine gun seal went down in a
hail of gunfire and was dead before he
hit the floor in the wake of his death
charges were filed against top meddling
cartel members including Escobar Escobar
was never brought to Justice in the U.S
but years later he would be slain whilst
trying to escape the police the whole
Saga had a far-reaching impact at the
top levels of government and opened up
years of debate and denial about
America's ongoing covert role in drug
smuggling regime change and revolution
in South America as for seal he died as
he'd lived in the most extremist
circumstances leaving behind a legacy is
one of the biggest and most Brazen
Smugglers who ever took to the skies
thanks for watching